hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well most students
actually which is a good well yeah give
me a paycheck hey that makes sense I
know I when I actually look at my like
bank statement I see like you know
numbers going up and so great now that I
feel good I see the breakdown back well
did you in finishing your test yeah
explosive that makes us doesn't even
like that sense of something that is
accomplished
mess around with this anymore that might
actually be more like a removal opinion
than the positive especially depending
on on how you're doing on what else
I don't think give yourself a lot of
pleasures yeah by eating yeah sometimes
I hear people complain about the
cafeteria that the food is pretty for
the most part it's nice to eat it's nice
to be able to choose what you want yeah
I remember when I was little army base
and there was only one meal for each
meal it was what they made and you need
yeah and you can have seconds if you
want because some people wouldn't even
eat yeah they usually just make enough
for everybody and if you don't like what
was being served that thing goes to too
bad
and then we went to this other base
where they had all these lots of service
because it was awesome aviation base
we're gonna change into an so I wanted
to walk to the mess hall
to do because there was like a pizza
line and a hamburger line salad line and
this line that line I was like eating
whatever it's nice what are you gonna do
tonight that'll be fun yeah drinking oh
yeah why do we like alcohol because it
gives us you know that that can hide
feeling and some people like that some
people like to drink so much thing they
like the auto-control feeling that comes
with it after one hour maybe not so much
if you have enough bad experiences and
we like the taste I mean if you could
just like shoot yourself up with alcohol
rather than go out to the bar or
get together with some friends over over
a 12-man would you do that I mean if all
you want no the alcohol is the sheer you
know kicking in then I suppose it makes
sense but you like other things about
alcohol right getting together with
friends
what sort of lubricates social
interactions because of loosens our
tongues that makes us a little bit less
inhibited some people like particular
drinks tastes you know you can spend a
lot of money on wine or on high-end
liquor or even beer these days that's
something we appreciate it's a pleasure
what else would you experience so you're
gonna eat some of you're gonna drink
listen to music yeah every what are you
probably listens to music every day
right why do we do it because we like it
because it's enjoyable it's a pleasure
now what would Cain's are you guys
getting insane that's that's extended
like what pains of you experience this
we did some of your sick that's no fun
right the coffin for example that's
that's nothing that fun hurts after a
while rib start earning any throat hurts
some of you may have headaches what else
exhaustion yeah if you're taking a test
and you can't then you actually can't
figure out some of the answers that
doesn't feel good right stress with
something that it's caused by college
students have to learn on the end of
stress if you guys are having a lot of
stress
our professors are smart well any other
things that you're not only 42 happening
yeah where it happened yeah well if you
drink too much then you get hungover
there's ways to get around that take
plenty of water
aspirin need sex appease is supposed to
help okay so let's let's think about
academic deals with us battlezone says
well we want to understand pains and
pleasures look at all the different
pains and pleasures we just talked about
are there Lee's reading classic weather
ways we can bring them together in
general habits and he does he says
there's some pains and pleasures that we
perceived through the bottom so for
instance you know when we drink we we
like the taste you know I like IPAs and
like very bitter beers so I enjoy that
taste other people they drink it and
that actually causes them the Panda oh
this tastes awful I don't want this it
tastes other things that people pour and
like well that's way too sweet for me
some people really like sweet things so
we Hannah pleasures of the senses and
have pains of the senses and then the
master includes intoxication as a
pleasure of the sense makes us do that
what are some of the pains of the senses
he talks about hunger and thirst you get
thirsty enough that hurts right you get
hungry enough to start actually feeling
hunger pains what else touch we enjoy
touching things quite a bit
you know smooth things over thing of
nice rough things aren't quite so nice
we enjoy the way our clothes that's
that's all about sense he talks about
other pleasures that come from observing
one's own activity this is kind of an
interesting idea because this wait rates
I'm gonna have to check this which is
the form of more awkward that's really
how many of you you know play it sport
of one form usually even just on the
weekends okay so you know that feeling
when things are actually coming together
you're not hung over you're properly
hydrated you actually stretched out and
now you're out there you're doing really
well whatever it is that you're doing
that's a pleasure of skill that's not
just census by themselves it's kind of a
mental thing we talk about mental and
physical mental and bodily pleasures not
being able to do things well that
produces a certain kind of pain in this
certain kind of discomfort when coming
to who've learned an instrument when you
were like K through 12 so you remember
the first starting out of the instrument
it really sound awful
make you feel bad it should be played
you're like oh my I can't believe this
sounds terrible
you play flute you know by Lyn you did
something different
violin for like a year it sounds terror
they actually figure out what you're
doing then you can actually play with
smoke coming from but it's all done it's
actually causing you pain and maybe the
only people thank you
what else sometimes we derive pleasure
by possessing something or by we have
pain by lacking some good thing so he
talks about well you know I mentioned
when I see my bank balance going up I
feel good I don't feel good because the
bank balance is something I can eat or
because I'm listening to it or something
like that it's just a bunch of numbers
but in my mind I'm thinking I actually
own something I feel the same thing when
I look at my retirement account and it
go this is totally irrational because
it's am I'm not gonna cash my retirement
account for decades but you know I will
get it you know from month to month
oh oh that's so good I feel good now the
way it goes down because the stock
market goes down oh I feel bad you know
well being you know disappointed
having your desires not gonna come true
we can allow them to hang out you know
if you give somebody something you can
then produce paints before they didn't
even know that they needed this thing
now you take it away they're like oh my
life is now incomplete because you took
away my carpets or my desk or they don't
have this anymore
people feel pain you don't think what
else do we take pleasures and and pains
in what about other people do we care
what they think about us or how they how
they feel about this
perceive us I bet all of you dude ready
to talk about parents you know not
wanting to disappoint them wanting them
to be proud of you
so none of them talks about a couple of
fancy talks about Hamid II don't think
Hannah would be damned to the horror
with that that's not connected to it at
all
that's the first Association good name
and what he calls piety and
corresponding to these there are pains
entity bill name now with Visa gets
particularly interested from the attila
terry perspective Anthony's a word for
friendship for people like feeling
positively towards when people are
feeling positively towards you they are
feeling a kind of pleasure in thinking
about you so if you and I are our
friends then I derive pleasure from
presence your company by thinking about
you and likewise you do for me here's
where it gets really interesting
I also derive pleasure from the fact
that you feel pleasure in thinking about
me the exit is sort of a reflexive you
know two-way relation if if I'm a good
teacher for example you like me as a
teacher you enjoy my class you know what
might be a sign of that I look at the
student evaluations I really like this
class if he wrote that evaluation he's
expressing a pleasure on his part which
then I am now taking pleasure in the
existence of so pleasures can build upon
each other in an interpersonal way
likewise pains of enmity you don't like
me you know you don't like me you know
honey honey love teachers here Kevin
interesting topic how do you like
teaching or do you do to them besides
students are you so all your professors
are great
yeah actually tired but I mean if you
like to literally put your hands down
start snoring
middle of somebody's lecture maybe
you're sending them a message they
you're no good right we care about how
other people see is piety and impiety
are basically like that with respect to
gas does God like me does he think I'm a
good guy or does he think I'm a bad guy
piety is taking pleasure and God liking
me get almighty taking pain at the fact
that God doesn't like what about Damon
goodnight we care about how people will
talk to us we care about the esteem that
they hold us in that's pretty
interesting
we're the only creature that cares about
that and we can sometimes that pleasure
or that pain can outweigh all the others
what else
so there's no other people to us put on
other people in another respect there's
what menthol calls no space benevolence
and there's lady calls
what are pleasures of benevolence
those are both elections both when I
open a twenty would openly do what was
sort of characteristic behavior we're
gonna be ever seen ever if it up that
might be a better place to start
we have benevolent societies state
troopers benevolent society I'm not sure
if New York as well making called
something different every state has one
of those large correctional officers
benevolent societies they call you up
and say can you contribute to us you
know to help people who their spouse was
a CEO or a state trooper they died in
the line of duty
like particular their spouses or
children in a while benevolence is being
good to somebody doing doing good things
for them
and if I like making you happy I am
actually taking pleasure to myself in
the pleasure that you feel not pleasure
that you feel because you like me like
anomie the pleasure that you feel just
because things have gotten better for
you
maybe pain has been taken away like
let's say I sneak into all of your you
guys I'm gonna dorm rooms most of you
I'm guessing but you know let's say I'm
a this huge project it's naked each one
of the places where you live at night
and they leave you like a care package
from a secret admirer because that kind
of weird your secret benefactor right
and it's got all sorts of stuff that
they like itunes giftcard maybe I like
jerky so we used to make jerky and
vegetarian eating there was somebody
else six-pack of beer all sorts of nice
things like that a whole bunch of your
cards do I don't know what you guys
actually liking different people like
different things you don't even know
it's me but I take pleasure in the fact
that you're going to get enjoyment
that's benevolence it doesn't matter
whether you know that it came from where
you have any positive feelings for me at
all I'm just happy that you're happy
that's why
we're doing two things some of the
people if we're taking the pleasure
internet we're taking pleasure the fact
that we're generating pleasure for other
people so the same thing to generate
pleasure twice they give you a candy bar
or you don't say I bring coffee and
donuts to class right you guys probably
I'm sure anybody say Buster Sadler he's
a jerk he brings us coffee and donuts I
don't like it but maybe they do know the
damn difference student evaluations
gonna be like oh this guy is trying to
get one over on us well let's say I just
do it a little semester you'd enjoy them
I don't even need to know that I get
enjoyment out of that doughnut by the
very fact that you're getting enjoyment
out of it if I'm the sort of person that
takes pleasure
what about malevolence if I hurt you and
I feel bad about hurting them so let's
say I scrape your car you park in the
Fontaine why can they be part of the fun
take the 110 to 25 feet and I see your
front of your parka the other one down
there let's say I go down there I won't
be a car scratch it out then you come
out dr. Sandler what are you doing oh
sorry I just got this thing fixed you
know I feel bad I feel bad because you
feel bad and also because you're
shouting again
but let's say you're not even showing
you just like flip you're feeling that I
feel bad because I did something
sometimes we actually take pleasure in
hurting people sometimes we take
pleasure
that's malevolence hurt somebody else
saves
like for example if I say alright pop
quiz on mental I never did a pop quiz in
this class before but this one's going
to happen it's gonna be worth a hundred
points how many missing six hundred then
be incredibly unfair and I make it super
hard
pop quiz right of these ten pages
you couldn't possibly do that right why
would I do something like because I like
hurting people
I like making students feel better I
don't wanna show you that you know you
don't know stuff although there are
there are some people take pain or take
pleasure in other people's pains or are
take pain and other people's pleasures
there are some people who see other
people having fun they're like I don't
like that they shouldn't be having that
fun there are people who feel pain down
um what else that he also talks about
more I'm running out of room on the
board so I can put it up here another
way much pleasures and pains are
generated from other pleasures and pains
time we have the past you know the
future you're not in the past anymore
right and then the future doesn't yet
exist and there's also the present what
do you call your your you know going
back to the past when I asked you about
what pains you felt with this last week
you were remembering right when you
remember something painful is that
memory painful for you candy do you like
to remember good times why because that
pleasure that you felt back then by
remembering it you are
again or feeling something like it in
the present
what about anticipating the future that
hasn't yet happened what are you guys
hoping is going to be the case you know
a year and a half from now for some of
you a semester from now you're gonna
walk across the stage right down there
in the valley and the parents and other
people are going to be there and I got a
boyfriend or girlfriend he or she told
me they are yeah feel really good aren't
you put that aside don't think about
that just the good stuff and then let's
listen like sweet the deal you're gonna
have a graduation party now we're gonna
get to invite all your friends at the
graduation party and do all the sort of
things we tend to do that parties
there's going to be gifts people are
gonna give you stuff and you're gonna
hopefully like the stuff that they give
it there won't be any stupid thoughtless
gifts like knickknacks that you can't
possibly yours
now that doesn't exist that could in
fact not it says you can drop out
tomorrow but you're already feeling a
sense of pleasure about thinking about
graduation aren't you and your career
after what about pleasures that are
gonna know that the presence that you're
not actually experiencing the same
imagination when you're watching a movie
you don't actually think
yeah some people but not you guys don't
write you're watching what's a recent
movie let's move you see they like yeah
okay oh I am you you don't want to be
possessed right but you enjoy watching
you know what happens and stuff like
that and now with horror movies actually
we can start to get a little creeped out
house but you don't really think you're
engaging in the imagination we enjoy
that you can also feel pains like that
you know imagine those commercials now
man that was made up I'm not saying it's
by the way but a man that was just made
up to make you feel bad and get you to
do something you are feeling pain by
watching yeah but it's over into
something that doesn't exist
that's the capacity of the imagination
lenders and pains can be generated but
all sorts of means they don't always
have to be physical you know things that
were in proximity with they can be
augmented diminished by the situation
that we're in by our interpersonal
relations by the factor of time these
are all things we want to take into
consideration when you're trying to
carry out a utilitarian calculation so
for example if you know that people
enjoy helping other people then the act
of helping other people doesn't just
generate one pleasure the pleasure for
the person is being helped it might
generate a pleasure for the other person
on the other hand you know we sometimes
compare ourselves against each other so
let's say I get one student special
attention like like for instance we know
you're in the military right next to
that so you know natural connection I
should talk with you all the time to
call upon you and treat you better than
than everybody else that's gonna make
him happy it's gonna make it's gonna
give him pleasure and it's gonna give me
pleasure to do that it's gonna take all
the rest of you off
right you're not gonna be happy about
that you're gonna feel a sense of envy
or unfairness notice how if we're doing
it to latarian calculations we have to
take all these things into consideration
how I orient myself in terms of
pleasures and pains towards another
person might affect somebody else might
increase his pleasure
might decrease it you know if you know
that you're the object of charity you
don't like being the object of charity
maybe my benevolence actually ticks you
off even though I feel good about you
know giving this happens all the time
patronize me that's what their that's
what they're objecting to so it's
important to keep all these into
consideration